- YOU DON'T KNOW.
YOU DON'T KNOW.
- [cackling]
- RACKIN' FRACKIN'
COMMUNITY SERVICE.
WORKING AROUND
A BUNCH OF GODDAMN NUT JOBS
WHO SIT AROUND
AND MUMBLE TO THEMSELVES.
[mumbling]
- IS EVERYTHING ALL RIGHT, SIR?
- OH, NEVER BETTER!
I LOVE THESE WACKY BASTARDS.
OH, YOU'RE A DAD, HUH?
YEAH, MY SON YELLED AT ME
'CAUSE I TIED HIM UP
OUTSIDE OF A BAR.
- YOU DID WHAT?
- OH, DON'T WORRY.
MY SON'S A TALKING BEAR.
- WHY DON'T YOU HAVE A SEAT?
THIS TALKING BEAR--DOES HE
EVER TELL YOU TO DO THINGS
THAT WOULD HURT YOURSELF
OR OTHERS?
- ARE YOU SHITTING ME?
THAT'S ALL HE DOES!
ONE TIME HE TURNED ME
INTO A FISH!
- I SEE.
- YEAH, HE CAN BE
A SARCASTIC LITTLE ASSHOLE,
BUT I KNOW HE LOVES ME,
'CAUSE ONE TIME I WAS GONNA GET
ON A SPACESHIP
WITH MY GIRLFRIEND,
AND HE SAVED ME
WITH A JET PACK.
- WE GOT A NUT JOB.
- LET ME TELL YOU ABOUT THE TIME
HE DIRECTED MY PORNO!
AAH!
ARE YOU [bleep] CRAZY?
I'M NOT CRAZY!
YOU'RE CRAZY!
- AND PUNCHITO!
CONGRATULATIONS, ETHEL.